On va s'arrêter là !
Pour faire fonctionner les appareils
de notre quotidien :
chauffage, éclairage, électroménager... Nous utilisons en moyenne
6 180 kilowattheures d'électricité par jour.
Et encore, c'est sans compter l'électricité utilisée indirectement
par les réseaux publics : le tramway, l'éclairage des rues,
la signalisation ou celle dont on a besoin pour faire tourner les usines.
Pour vous donner une idée, avec ma petite installation,
cela reviendrait à pédaler à très bonne
allure en permanence.
Heureusement, nous avons d'autres solutions
pour répondre à nos besoins en énergie.
Pour autant, cette électricité
ne nous tombe pas du ciel.
Exactement !
Elle provient d'une multitude de centrales
et d'installations qui prennent des formes différentes
et surtout qui transforment en électricité des sources d'énergie différentes.
Aujourd'hui, il faut jongler entre toutes
ces différentes options de production
pour répondre au mieux à notre besoin
croissant en énergie.
Merci Gaspard ! Je vois que tu es au courant.
Elle est facile celle-là.
C'est ce qu'on appelle le mix énergétique et c'est ce dont nous allons
vous parler aujourd'hui en duo
Le mix énergétique,
c'est le nom que l'on donne
à la combinaison des différents types
d'énergie dans notre production
et notre consommation d'énergie.
Aujourd'hui, nous allons essentiellement nous concentrer sur l'électricité.
Et vous allez voir, il y a de quoi faire !
Pour démêler tout cela,  je suis accompagné de Gaspard.
Il va nous emmener découvrir la réalité
de ce mix énergétique sur le terrain.
Mais c'est surtout quelqu'un de très pointu
sur les grands enjeux de notre planète
et en particulier
tout ce qui concerne l'énergie.
On peut dire ça Gaspard ?
Alors justement,
si la question du mix énergétique
nous préoccupe aujourd'hui,
c'est parce qu'il y a urgence à améliorer la part
que représentent ces fameuses énergies renouvelables
dans cette production globale.
Je vais donc vous emmener voir
du solaire, de l'éolien
et même des centres particulièrement stratégiques
dans la gestion de notre consommation électrique.
Commençons par les fondamentaux.
Il faut savoir qu'on ne produit pas
d'énergie à proprement parler.
On la prend quelque part sous une forme
et on la transforme de manière à la rendre facilement transportable,
et utilisable.
En énergie électrique typiquement.
Prenons un exemple concret : une centrale à charbon.
Le charbon extrait du sol contient une énergie chimique
qu'il libère sous forme de chaleur
lorsqu'il brûle.
Cette chaleur va ensuite chauffer de l'eau qui se transforme en vapeur
qui fait tourner un générateur,
lequel produit de l'électricité.
Malheureusement,
ce processus génère des produits secondaires.
Le charbon émet du CO2, du dioxyde de carbone quand il brûle,
ainsi que des particules fines nocives
pour notre santé.
Autre souci, ce charbon n'est pas présent partout.
Et puis, il faut aussi l'extraire,
ce qui n'est pas sans conséquence.
Il s'épuise.
C'est là qu'interviennent les énergies dites renouvelables.
Je m'explique.
Ces énergies sont issues de sources inépuisables.
Le rayonnement solaire, le mouvement de l'air ou de l'eau.
Elles sont également issues
de sources renouvelables ou renouvelées,
comme les déchets avec la méthanisation.
Pas besoin d'extraire un combustible ici ou là
avec toutes les implications que cela peut avoir
qu'elles soient écologiques ou politiques.
Bien sûr, il faut des matériaux
pour construire les installations.
Mais une fois en place, elles sont tout à fait propres.
Pour résumer, donner plus de place
aux énergies renouvelables
permet de ralentir les changements climatiques,
développer les territoires et aussi gagner en indépendance énergétique.
Que du bon !
Toutefois, pour en tirer pleinement parti et favoriser leur utilisation,
elles demandent une gestion fine
et intelligente.
Ici, nous sommes dans un centre
de conduite de ces énergies renouvelables
à Châlons-en-Champagne.
Une équipe de 15 personnes supervise 1 000 éoliennes et 130 centrales solaires
qui produisent annuellement
l'équivalent de la consommation électrique de 3 millions de personnes.
24h/24 et 7j/7.
Sur ces écrans,
on voit en direct la production
en électricité de toutes ces installations
et on peut les surveiller à distance
et vérifier leur bon fonctionnement.
Pourquoi un tel dispositif ?
Il faut bien comprendre qu'à grande
échelle, l'électricité ne se stocke pas.
Une fois produite, elle est envoyée sur le réseau depuis les
différents sites pour être convoyée
et directement utilisée.
Cet équilibre se fait à l'échelle nationale.
Il faut ajuster en permanence
la production d'électricité
des différentes installations
avec la demande.
Tenez, ici, on voit en temps réel
la part des différentes énergies produites à l'échelle nationale.
Le 24 mars 2022, à midi pétante.
En jaune, c'est le nucléaire : 60%.
En bleu : 7%,
ce sont les barrages hydrauliques.
Ils sont propres et assez faciles à adapter en fonction de la demande.
En turquoise : 3%,
L'éolien.
Et là, en orange,
c'est le solaire : 16%.
Logique, il est midi.
Effectivement la particularité de l'énergie solaire
et dans une moindre mesure,
celle de l'énergie éolienne.
C'est qu'elles sont variables en fonction des conditions climatiques.
Alors, pour compléter cette gestion fine, une des meilleures stratégies
vise à multiplier les sources
et les installations en fonction
des spécificités de chaque territoire.
Et ça, Jamy ça s'appelle le foisonnement.
Ça permet de lisser la production,
comme on dit dans le jargon. Je suis un pro.
Et ça tombe bien parce qu'on ne peut pas dire
que nous ayons trop d'installations
à l'heure actuelle.
Les énergies renouvelables représentent 19%
de la production électrique en France.
Et clairement, c'est en dessous
des recommandations
de l'ensemble de la communauté scientifique.
Et en dessous des objectifs
que la France s'est elle même fixés.
Aujourd'hui, c'est encore l'hydraulique
qui représente la part la plus importante,
mais clairement la plus forte progression.
C'est l'éolien Jamy !
Ah c'est magnifique les éoliennes !
Eh bien, je crois que tu as trouvé
ta prochaine destination.
Bon, le temps que Gaspard se déplace
pour aller prendre l'air
au sens propre du terme,
profitons en pour faire un point sur l'éolien justement.
Dans les grandes lignes, c'est assez simple.
Généralement, produire un courant électrique consiste
à faire tourner un aimant au sein d'une
bobine de fil conducteur ou l'inverse.
C'est ainsi que fonctionnent tous les générateurs.
D'ailleurs, ça ressemble déjà un peu
à une éolienne.
À quelques détails près.
Tout l'art d'une éolienne est donc
de capter au mieux l'énergie du vent.
Une énergie dite cinétique due à la masse et à la vitesse de l'air déplacé.
De la transformer en une énergie mécanique.
Le mouvement de ses pâles, qui vont ensuite faire tourner le générateur
et induire une énergie électrique.
Pour y parvenir,
les éoliennes sont munies de trois pales en général.
Elles sont profilées comme les ailes d'un avion
pour tourner au mieux sous l'effet du vent.
L'ensemble permet de mettre en rotation un axe qui alimente ensuite le générateur.
Le tout est perché en haut d'un mât
pour être bien exposé au vent,
car l'énergie déployée par une masse d'air dépend en grande partie
de sa vitesse de déplacement.
Or, en général, le vent est plus fort
en altitude, qu'au ras des pâquerettes.
Alors effectivement, l'exposition au vent, c'est le nerf de la guerre.
Typiquement en dessous de 10 kilomètres par heure,
le vent est trop faible pour permettre aux éoliennes de tourner.
Il arrive aussi que le vent souffle trop fort,
mais c'est quand même beaucoup plus rare.
Lorsqu'on installe un parc éolien on cherche
donc un endroit où le vent souffle suffisamment fort
et suffisamment régulièrement, comme c'est le cas ici.
Et dis donc Jamy, c'est vachement haut !
Je vais peut-être descendre. Ce sera plus pratique pour vous parler.
Ici, nous sommes au milieu du parc
de la forêt de Thivolet.
Cette zone a été choisie parce qu'il y a de la place,
parce que les éoliennes peuvent s'intégrer dans le paysage,
mais surtout parce que le vent souffle.
Concrètement, on recherche plutôt une courbe comme celle-là.
Des éoliennes qui tournent en moyenne entre 75% et 95% du temps.
Si elles ne tournent pas, c'est que le vent est trop faible,
trop fort, c'est plus rare, ou qu'elles sont en maintenance.
Un parc comme celui-ci représente
la consommation électrique
de près de 14000 personnes.
Alors, à l'échelle nationale, on essaie de multiplier les zones
d'implantation des parcs éoliens.
De la même manière qu'on multiplie
les sources d'énergies renouvelables.
Le mieux étant de choisir des zones soumises
à des régimes venteux différents pour qu'à tout moment
on puisse compter sur une partie
de ce parc global éparpillé
un peu partout sur le territoire.
Et pour continuer d'en installer
toujours plus, il faut de la place.
Exactement !
Mais il y a un endroit où il y a de la place et pas mal de vent.
C'est en mer.
On appelle cela l'éolien offshore.
Au delà des côtes, ces parcs se développent un peu partout dans le monde
car la technologie commence à devenir
très compétitive.
Leur impact sur la biodiversité
marine est étudié de près
pour être constamment diminué.
Ces éoliennes ont l'avantage de produire ou plutôt
de transformer de grandes quantités
d'énergie éolienne en énergie électrique.
Alors que la puissance maximale
d'une éolienne terrestre est généralement comprise entre 1,8 et 3 mégawatts.
Les éoliennes offshore atteignent facilement 6 à 8 mégawatts,
et c'est sans compter
les projets d'éoliennes offshore actuels
qui visent
une bonne quinzaine de mégawatts.
Certains parcs rivalisent d'ailleurs
déjà avec des centrales nucléaires,
notamment dans les mers septentrionales : la mer du Nord, la mer Baltique.
Le vent au large des côtes est plus
puissant et plus régulier que sur terre.
D'ailleurs, en France aussi,
de nombreux projets sont en train
de sortir de terre, enfin de mer.
Ces projets de grande envergure
sont indispensables pour réussir
un changement global dans nos méthodes
de production de l'électricité.
Et on le sait,
ce changement est urgent. Mais ce n'est pas la seule voie.
Il existe des solutions qui fonctionnent très bien
pour les projets de grande comme de petite envergure
et qui sont parfaitement adaptés
à notre environnement.
C'est le cas des panneaux photovoltaïques.
Ils tirent parti d'une énergie tout aussi
illimitée et abondante que le vent,
celle que nous procure le Soleil.
Gaspard, il est temps de mettre les voiles et d'aller
prendre le soleil s'il est là.
Avec plaisir !
Ça commence à cailler par ici.
Il y a deux fondamentaux indispensables à la compréhension du fonctionnement
de ces panneaux.
D'une part, ils sont en silicium et
comme toute la matière qui nous entoure,
ce silicium est composé
d'atomes.
Des grains de matière
constitués d'un noyau autour
duquel se baladent des électrons.
D'autre part, il faut savoir qu'un courant électrique,
c'est justement une circulation d'électrons.
Le but est donc d'obtenir une circulation d'électrons
entre les atomes de silicium
et plus généralement
entre les deux couches de silicium
qui composent un panneau.
Pour y parvenir, il faut créer d'un côté
un surplus d'électrons et de l'autre
un déficit d'électrons.
Sur la couche supérieure, on va donc
ajouter des atomes de phosphore,
des atomes qui possèdent un surplus d'électrons.
Ils sont donc porteurs d'une charge négative. Sur la couche inférieure,
on y place des atomes de bore, eux,
présentent un déficit d'électrons,
une charge positive.
Quand le dispositif se retrouve exposé à la lumière du Soleil,
les électrons sont excités par cet apport d'énergie et ils sont prêts
à circuler du haut vers le bas,
ou plus précisément du moins vers le plus.
Il suffit de connecter les deux couches
avec un fil conducteur et un courant
se crée, alimentant au passage
les appareils qui sont reliés au système.
Comme je le disais, l'avantage des panneaux photovoltaïques,
c'est qu'ils peuvent facilement
être installés un peu partout.
Sur le toit de nos maisons, des bâtiments agricoles,
des bâtiments publics, industriels,
des grandes surfaces...
Il y a de la place.
Effectivement, selon une étude qui date de 2019,
en Europe, on pourrait couvrir un quart
de nos besoins en électricité
en recouvrant nos toits de panneaux
solaires.
Quand c'est possible, bien sûr.
Ce genre d'initiative peut également
s'accompagner de projets plus ambitieux.
Typiquement, il est possible d'installer
de véritables parcs photovoltaïques,
comme pour l'éolien. Regarde derrière moi !
Bon, et tant qu'à faire pour ce genre
d'installation,
on essaie de choisir des zones
ou l'ensoleillement est optimal.
Comme ici à Luxey, dans le Sud-Ouest.
On n'est pas sûr un 100% de justesse
là, niveau météo.
Sur ce site de 25 hectares, près de 40000 panneaux sont installés
pour une puissance de 12 mégawatts.
C'est moins qu'un parc éolien offshore,
mais ça représente tout de même la consommation de 7 400 personnes.
Et une fois que ces panneaux
sont construits et installés,
ils fournissent une électricité propre.
Alors il faut veiller à entretenir le parc régulièrement
et s'assurer de son bon fonctionnement.
Autre avantage, on peut concilier sur le même espace
deux activités, ici, avec un élevage de moutons par exemple.
Allez viens ! On va les chercher !
Ne les comptez pas !
Ce n'est pas le moment de s'endormir,
car il faut bien garder à l'esprit que ces installations ne sont pas éternelles.
Un panneau solaire a une durée de vie moyenne de 30 ans.
Au bout d'un moment, il faudra en changer et le remplacer par un autre.
Cela pose la question du cycle de vie.
Pour les produire, tout d'abord, il faut
de l'énergie et des matières premières.
Du silicium en grande quantité, dont l'extraction et le raffinage
ont des impacts environnementaux
et sociaux, particulièrement en Chine.
Cependant, des producteurs européens
et même français
parviennent à limiter considérablement les impacts.
On est sur la bonne voie.
Question fin de vie, ces panneaux
sont recyclables à 95%, voire 99%
Et plus il y en a, plus la filière se développe.
Côté éolien, maintenant, là aussi, les choses avancent.
Plus de 90% du poids d'une éolienne
est recyclable.
Bon, après le démantèlement, il reste les pales.
Mais il existe des filières pour les valoriser énergétiquement
et certaines pales 100% recyclables
et éco-conçues commencent à voir le jour.
Ce n'est pas encore parfait donc, mais
il faut garder en tête que malgré cela,
ces installations émettent au final des dizaines de fois
moins de CO2 par kilowattheure
produit que les énergies fossiles.
Une raison de plus
pour explorer toutes les pistes
et développer les différentes filières.
Dans cette vidéo, nous avons beau
nous être concentrés sur l'éolien
et le solaire, deux secteurs
très emblématiques,
il ne faut pas non plus oublier le reste.
L'hydroélectricité évidemment, qui est
l'une des plus anciennes EnR du monde.
Il y a aussi le biogaz produit à partir de déchets agricoles notamment.
La géothermie, très prisée en Islande, mais qui est aussi utilisée en France,
qui repose sur la gestion de la chaleur du sous sol.
On peut aussi penser à la force marémotrice,
qui s'appuie sur les va et vient de la marée,
ou les hydroliennes qui récupèrent
l'énergie des courants marins.
Bref, des sources d'énergie intarissables et adaptées aux spécificités
de chaque territoire.
L'idée, en fait,
c'est de ne pas mettre tous nos œufs
dans le même panier,
de parier sur une multitude de solutions.
C'est ça le mix énergétique.
En plus,
la question du stockage de l'énergie
est aussi une des clés
pour encourager le développement
des énergies variables.
On produit au maximum en permanence et on stocke le surplus
pour le réutiliser plus tard.
Il y a une dernière chose qu'il ne faut jamais perdre de vue.
La seule énergie propre est celle
qu'on ne consomme pas.
La sobriété ça ne peut donc pas faire de mal.
À grande échelle, évidemment, mais aussi à titre individuel, quand c'est possible.
Et d'ailleurs, Jamy
tu pourras me rendre mon vélo parce que là, j'ai 2h de marche jusque chez moi.
Euh oui, il faut simplement que je remette la main sur la roue.
Enfin, la bonne nouvelle, c'est que
comme ça, il n'y a plus besoin d'antivol